para nadie era un secreto que emanuel a
maco buscará ser reelegido como
presidente de la república se esperaba
era el día del anuncio y finalmente fue
este jueves en la noche a través de una
carta que fue publicada en varios
diarios regionales de todo el país una
carta extensa dirigida a los franceses
en donde el presidente hace por una
parte un balance de lo que han sido
estos cinco años de gobierno donde ella
subraya logros como la disminución de
los impuestos mayor inversión en la
salud también en la seguridad y
disminución de la tasa de desempleo la
más baja de los últimos 15 años pero
maicon también es consciente de que han
sido cinco años de muchísimas crisis en
especial estos dos últimos años de
pandemia y en medio de todo esto pues él
pide a los franceses que le vuelvan a
dar a su confianza para los próximos
cinco años en esta carta del presidente
no da a conocer cuál va a ser su
programa de gobierno cuáles serían las
grandes líneas pero da algunas luces por
una parte un proyecto muy centrado en la
economía en la independencia económica
del país sobre todo energética y por
otra parte un lugar muy importante para
la educación la escuela que debe ser un
lugar de oportunidades para y donde los
maestros deben ser respetados y mejor
remunerados con termina esta carta
diciendo que esta campaña no va a tener
la forma no va a tomar la forma que él
esperaba en medio de este contexto
internacional en el que se está viviendo
con este conflicto entre ucrania y rusia
así que eso es lo que resta por saber
cómo va a hacer esta campaña cómo van a
hacer los debates con los demás
candidatos y sobre todo cuándo será su
primer mitin de campaña porque
justamente el primero el que se tenía
previsto para este sábado fue cancelado
en medio de la situación que se está
viviendo aquí